Salut aujourd'hui on est mercredi et je crois qu'il y a une information hyper importante : Joey Starr a frappé Gilles Verdez ! PAN !
Comme ça : Grosse patte bien lourde ... Et ça a failli assommer Verdez.
Comme sur la chaine le mercredi c'est le jour des astuces je vais vous donner une astuce pour pas vous prendre une baffe comme Gilles Verdez !
On peut éviter ça =)
TROIS ASTUCES POUR EVITER DE VOUS FAIRE GIFLER !
Première astuce : Il faut déjà respecter la distance d'intimité entre deux personnes quand ces deux personnes ne se connaissent pas.
On a tous une distance d'intimité. On peut symboliser ça par une bulle.
À partir du moment où cette distance-là, personnelle, est franchie on se sent agressé.
Si Joey Starr est agressif au point de taper la personne c'est vraiment qu'il se sent agressé physiquement lui aussi dans son intimité, dans sa propre intimité.
Attention je dit pas que c'est bien ce qu'il a fait !
Je dit juste que ça s'explique par ça et comme Joey Starr est pas d'un naturel à dire: "Excusez-moi pardon mais je crois que vous êtes en train de me déranger !"
Il y en a qui sont plus tactiles, qui n'ont pas de soucis mais en tout cas quand vous approchez de quelqu'un que vous ne connaissez pas, essayez d'abord de jauger cette distance-là :D
DEUXIÈME ASTUCE !
Si vous savez que de toute manière vous êtes entrez dans la bulle, que de toute manière c'est votre but ... regardez les réactions de la personne, essayez d'anticiper un peu le mouvement.
Parce que évidemment il y a des signes, on voit nettement dans la vidéo le moment où Joey Starr va s’apprêter à taper:
Il se sent agressé, il a un geste de recul (on va dire que c'est sa défense initiale).
Et quand un prédateur se défend ... OUI on peut dire que Joey Starr est un prédateur =)
Ça veut dire que derrière il va attaquer, il va attaquer pour se défendre !
Et la TROISIÈME astuce, qui est la plus importante c'est d'éviter le conflit !!!
Si y'a pas de conflit HEHE ... il n'y a pas de baffe !
C'est pour cela que je vous recommande la CNV : La Communication Non Violente !
C'est tout une méthodologie qui à été développée dans les années 60 par Marshall Rosenberg.
Ca a été popularisé ensuite en France par cet homme quand il est sorti, le livre : "Cessez d'être gentil, soyez vrai", puisqu'il parle de la CNV à l'interieur.
C'est basé sur quatre fondamentaux:
1/ Toute situation doit pouvoir être observée sans juger les autres
2/ Chacun doit apprendre à exprimer son propre ressenti
3/ Chacun doit apprendre à exprimer ses besoins (son besoin d'une manière générale) puisque ...
4/ ... le quatrièmement c'est : chacun doit apprendre à exprimer son attente vis à vis de l'autre.
Au lieu de se laisser guider et submerger par ses émotions il vaut mieux les exprimer, ça permet de se dissocier de cette émotion
que ce soit la colère, la déception ...
Le fait de les exprimer ça va vous empêcher de faire une réaction réflexe, non réfléchie.
Quand vous êtes dans une discussion avec quelqu'un et que le ton monte, que la personne devient agressive, même si c'est pas de votre fait peu importe ...
... la première chose que nous enseigne la CNV c'est de ne pas essayer d'argumenter !
Notre premier réflexe c'est d'argumenter pour avoir raison.
Mais d'avoir raison sur ce qu'il se dit et on le sait c'est pas ça le fondement du problème.
C'est jamais ce qu'il se dit le vrai fondement du problème !
Contrôlez votre envie d'argumenter en laissant l'autre parler.
Vous le laissez parler, laissez le s'exprimer c'est pas un soucis, ne le prenez pas personnellement.
De toute manière c'est pas contre vous et retenez toutes vos envies de le contredire même si vous avez raison ou que vous pensez que vous avez raison.
Prenez un temps, essayez de déduire ce que vit l'autre émotionnellement et faites lui une réponse miroir.
Si par exemple je rencontre une personne, je fais un tour à cette personne, cette personne s’énerve à la fin, elle me dit :
"Dis-moi comment ça marche ce tour, dis-moi comment tu as fait !"
Qu'elle monte dans l'énervement pour avoir l'explication je vais plutôt prendre en compte cette colère, chercher pourquoi il est en colère et comme réponse miroir je vais lui faire une affirmation suivie d'une question.
"Je vois que t'es très très en colère, je vois que t'es très énervé, peut-être parce que tu penses que je t'insulte en faisant quelque chose que tu n'as pas compris ?!
C'est normal que tu ne l'aies pas compris puisque personne ne le comprend, c'est mon métier de faire ça, d'essayer de bluffer les gens.
Peut-être que tu subis une frustration à cause de ça et que toi aussi tu voudrais apprendre quelque chose pour bluffer les gens !"
Peut-être quelque chose de différent.
Prendre son point de vue à lui dès le départ, de se mettre à sa place, ça permet de désamorcer et ça évite le ... *CLAP* *cri légendaire de Joey*
Et sans violence on est quand même beaucoup mieux !
En attendant cette histoire sur Joey Starr et Gilles Verdez c'est en train de faire une émule de ouf puisque Cyril Hanouna refuse de présenter TPMP ce soir.
Je ne sais pas si c'est une bonne nouvelle ou une mauvais nouvelle.
Je ne me positionne pas car je suis dans la communication non violente.
J’espère que vous avez aimé cette astuce du mercredi, si c'est le cas faites-le moi savoir en mettant un ... POUCE EN L'AIR !
Je voudrais vous dire merci d'une chose : merci de sous-titrer les vidéos, vous êtres nombreux et nombreuses à le faire.
Si vous ne le faites pas encore et que ça vous amuse n'hésitez pas, ça permet d'ouvrir toutes les vidéos aux malentendants.
Merci à tout ceux qui le font.
N'hésitez pas à laisser un petit commentaire que je lirai.
Vous pouvez également vous abonnez à la chaine et rendez-vous demain à 17h pour le prochain Mental Vlog ... CIAO !!! =)